[Applaudissements]
tune oui ce qu'ils vont tout changer
ces deux villes un port de faire un haut
personnage qui donne son avis sur la
ténue je trouve ça ne l'aiment pas non à
un million et ça fait 23 % donc je pense
qu'ils vont le garder mais je préfère
arthur il donne des boissons donne les
bonbons aux invités les bonbons et au
public après quand les invités ils
mangent pas ne pas normaliser le maquis
d'axwell sur la télé vas-y alors c'est
toi combattu tu mets bien asie tu veux
des émissions tout seul départ
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la pros qui doit dérangeante un moment
pour moi qui t'arrive je regardais les
amours qu'il faut à peu près un million
23% pas marché et aujourd'hui on a
trouvé la candidate bouffe avec sa
pancarte avec cette jeune fille à celle
fils et huit enfants blessés monsieur
schéma qui vous n'êtes pas tout à fait
non